let's jump into the first story and let
me just get started with two words civil
war
yup i had to say it because everybody
was waiting for it the fire emojis are
already in the chat
fed's search home of jeffrey clark
former doj official who pushed trump's
false election fraud claims
they say clark is a former doj lawyer
who former president donald trump sought
to install as attorney general in the
days before the january 6 capital riot
as top officials refused to go along
with his vote fraud claims it wasn't
clear what investigators were seeking at
clark's home but the raid was part of
the justice department's sweeping
investigation into the effort to
overturn the 2020 elections according to
sources familiar with the matter now
what we're hearing from conservatives
and republicans is that jeffrey clark
was simply trying to understand and
investigate the claims that were being
made on the left they're saying he's an
insurrectionist who is going along with
trump's schemes
i don't think either narrative matters
what matters is the narratives exist
if you're on the left and you're looking
at this you're like yes the federal
government is going after trump and his
opponents
certainly then you think trump's tried
staging a coup and we're in the midst of
some very serious crisis or you're a
trump supporter and you're like this
dude wasn't doing anything wrong and the
weight of the doj is crushing down on
their political rivals i i happen to
think that the doj the january sex
committee is just trying to stop trump
from winning that's my opinion but
either way it looks like this country is
being completely ripped apart
yep you know i've said it once and i
will say it again in 2016
when there were accusations made that
the presidential election was rigged we
investigated the accused in 2020 when
the same accusation was made we decided
to investigate the accuser make of that
what you want i just don't like how the
left is
the anti-police state side quote-unquote
the you know anti-prison industrial
complex but if it's somebody who we
don't know why yet if we know why and
the dude did something wrong okay but we
don't know why yet and just to see
democrats blindly be like yes queen and
like so excited that just trump
supporters are being uh arrested or
searched or whatever i don't love
i would assume that clark probably knew
this was coming he probably knew it was
coming you look at what the doj has done
at the sham committee they've gone after
steve bannon mark meadows anybody even
affiliated associated with trump anybody
that was texting with him uh tweeting
with him even days prior this is all
about trump this is that sham committee
and it's an illegitimate committee quite
often uh jeffrey clark i'm pretty sure
he was subpoenaed and he uh pleaded the
fifth
so i wonder if this is retaliation for
him refusing to to actually answer those
questions because you know what the
january 6 committee is doing i'll tell
you anybody who's testified for for the
january 6 committee you've been played
you watch the videos they're putting out
they're pulling quotes out of context
that's what they wanted it's a
non-adversarial committee there's no
cross-examination so they're just
getting people to say whatever they want
they're taking interviews with the trump
sphere and getting out of context it's a
show trial it's a sham
and now they're using the weight of the
federal government to crush anybody who
is supporting trump and it's all
one-sided because there's no republicans
on it yeah exactly so yeah mccarthy
asked me to be one of the five and i
wanted to be but for your listeners you
need to understand that this is the
first time in the history of congress
has a speaker ever rejected a minority
leader's picks to be on a [ __ ] committee
it's never happened before she didn't
like jim jones she didn't like jim banks
and some of the others so we're not on
it but we're doing our own thing because
i think it's a i think it's clearly
meant to manipulate people who don't pay
attention so they go it's a bipartisan
committee because we have
cheney yeah right
i feel like if we're talking about
actual political arguments the real
factions are libertarians and
conservatives
because liberals are just saying
whatever random crazy nonsense i just
don't even understand they're like liz
cheney's great i'm like what yeah you
hated the chinese where are you what no
one in the cheney family has ever gotten
us like hyped up on fears of terrorism
or anything like that to strip people of
their civil liberties i don't think we
have anything to worry about here
wow the apple doesn't fall far from the
tree huh yeah if you've been watching
the hearings in in liz uh the first
hearing 20 minutes pretty sleepy
she must have a serious crush on trump
because she mentioned his name over and
over and over again but truly i think
what it is she despises him she thinks
about him when he she wakes up and and
when she goes to sleep she's thinking
about because she despises him everybody
on that committee they hate him and i
believe uh tim you're absolutely right
this is about trump in 2024. there's no
other reason for this of course i can't
talk about inflation and gas so it's all
about january 6. and i think it's having
a uh sadly a little bit of an impact and
maybe that's why you're seeing desantis
numbers improve a little bit yeah well
you like desantis though i'm not saying
he's not a good guy i'm just saying that
i think that as they as they continue to
do this it's all one-sided uh and you
keep it on keep it on i was watching ms
lsd the other day and
and cnn and that's how you saw trump
trump trump's name on it so they're
trying to convince the american people
it's like they think he's still
president or something yeah yeah it's
been two years man go home blue and on
bro yeah
they think he's secretly stole the
president i gotta say i agree with you
and you would uh you know it's
unfortunate because like you said it is
having something of an effect but if it
wasn't you'd almost just call it a weird
group therapy session they're all just
getting together to vent about how much
they didn't like trump and he was bad it
just seems like a very emotionally
satisfying thing for them rather than
something serious people are engaging in
for good reasons they're just all trauma
bonding yeah really this is i so robert
barnes was on he was saying he doesn't
think they're gonna actually criminally
charge trump or even do a criminal
referral because if they do then then
it's ron desantis
but what they want to do is demonize
trump enough to where they'll have
something to campaign on so come 2024
trump comes out and he's like you know
i'm going to be running again and then
they're going to be like remember all of
that crazy stuff we showed you and the
fbi oh don't vote for that guy he's oh
it's the end of days
that's what they want right
it's russia 2.0 right exactly that i
wanted to ask you about that which is do
you think your constituents because when
i go on twitter and you know the people
i follow are
a lot of them are
famous hollywood people or people on the
left still
and even my people on the right like
everyone's kind of talking about it do
real people care about this or do real
people just want to talk about the
economy like are there
working poor constituents who are coming
up to you talking about january 6 like
is it an issue that affects real people
right now i think the i think when they
uh the people that talked about it they
said there's very few people watching
this stuff listen they cannot talk about
inflation they can't talk about gas
prices but the mom and dad and everybody
else that's paying five bucks for fuel
that's what has that's what's on their
mind the food all of it the inflation
eight and a half percent so what else
are the democrats going to play right i
mean this is i mean really quite
honestly they're pretty clever about
this right let's just talk about january
6 because we can just beat trump every
day beat him beating beating beat him
because they don't want him coming back
in 2024. now i hope he comes back
because i think he'll be the 47th
president if he comes back he will be
lost can you imagine i
don't know i do
coming back can you just imagine like
being at a gas station
and then all of a sudden you hear
someone just yell out and anger like
guys son of a ra and you're like oh man
you must have saw the gas prices and you
walk over gas prices no no i'm watching
the january 6 hearing and there's that
viking guy
like uh shaman
he came so close to losing it all that
day
this is this is so hysterical the entire
narrative he's the sitting president of
the united states at this point has
complete control over the military right
he's the commander-in-chief and his
attempt at an insurrection is to like
vaguely dog whistle that people enter a
building without weapons
yeah basically it was what if anything
we learned he's really bad at
insurrection
so we should all feel we should all feel
safer for a third term like yo homeboy
tried it and he was not good at it
second second term second second you
know they're pretty clever too because
they they show the worst few minutes of
footage and they'll show law enforcement
officers get hurt and there's not a law
enforcement officer across the country
that that would support any law
enforcement officer getting hurt and no
and if you assaulted a law enforcement
officer that day go to prison not jail
go to prison lock them up and i think we
would all agree with that yes but i tell
you something when
i give tours of that capital today and i
gave it last week and when you go
through that beautiful statutory hall if
the individuals inside that building
wanted to destroy that building they
could have there's monuments everywhere
there's paintings they could have
destroyed it but they chose not to
because most of the people inside that
building didn't do anything wrong they
were there they shouldn't have been
there but in quite honestly they
shouldn't have done they didn't do
anything wrong one guy got acquitted of
all charges
so a video showing the cop waving him in
yeah yeah well and it's true i mean
there's a nuance right you did have
people on one side of the building who
were rioting who broke the doors down on
the other side of the building the
police removed the barriers opened the
doors waved people in those people
didn't do anything wrong
the people who broke in and were causing
problems did one one guy tried claiming
that he was let in and there's a video
of him climbing through a broken window
and they're like nah
i don't think so
they texted me said smell for the pie
then punch with cover your fist with a
bandana punch it
i want to know if they're going to
charge the dog i mean triumph the dog
now with online oh that's right no one
charges triumph my point is like even
even when you look at the people who did
break the law who should be prosecuted
it still wasn't an insurrection
well and this was kind of maybe this is
a stretch to him but this was you know
occupy is you had normal people marching
peacefully which is our right to do and
then you had people destroying property
and those are very those are two very
different groups of people of course
well
with january 6 it is fair to point out
is it the capital building and there was
an effort to count the electoral votes
so it's bad that gets disrupted that
that puts it on a special level but it
was a riot it was a riot and a really
really bad one right and and there's and
and there's questions about security and
and how we should be handling this
but the funny thing is uh on january
20th 2017
hundreds of black-clad far leftists
romped through dc smashing windows and
setting fires attacking people and they
were all arrested and they were almost
all of them were acquitted except for
the people who actually pleaded guilty
because they didn't immediately they
made a mistake yeah a bunch of people
just said no matter what not guilty and
then the uh the progressive lawyers and
legal apparatus were able to get these
people out lawsuits were filed and the
city ended up having to pay the people
they arrested some of them
and uh one of them i think was a
journalist
so
it's funny when when the far left
rampages through dc during trump's
inauguration government doesn't care but
when you come to the government's house
all of a sudden they're going to put the
boot on you it shows you who they're
really willing to protect it's not you
it's them but only sometimes when you go
to the government's house right because
we cannot forget the 529 539 yeah were
they they surrounded
what was it 1500 uh federal agencies
150. i'm sorry 50 yeah yeah
look i'm charging 150 million
yeah 150 uh federal agents were injured
they surrounded the white house the
president literally had to retreat into
a bunker and what was the response
laughter people were laughing at the
president
is do the republicans have a plan on
holding a 529 uh commission select
committee to uh i don't believe so
well so but you know about 529 don't go
ahead i don't the uh thousands of far
leftists ripped down the barricades in
front of the white house
tried tearing the fence down
set fire to a white house guard post set
fire to st john's church the president
was ushered into an emergency bunker out
of fear for his safety
and
uh journalists were injured 150 officers
got injured throughout the protests
there is a there is a photo from for an
aerial photo of dc showing fires all
over the city
it was it was so much worse than january
6. but i got to tell you man troy you
see i think the issue is the democrats
they play offense they hold these
committees republicans don't do it why
don't why don't the republicans announce
a select committee on on 529 and start
bringing in people filing subpoenas
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you